[Music]
okay
i think we're we're live sir we're live
so
good evening everyone and welcome to the
first children's scrutiny
meeting of this municipal year and
before we begin could i just remind
everybody that the meeting is being
recorded
and could i request that members mute
the microphones
unless they're speaking um if during the
course of the meeting
you want to ask a question could you
please indicate that
in the chat facility or use the raised
hand facility
um as we've got some new members on the
committee this year
i'm going to ask that we go around and
just introduce ourselves so
my name is denise weston i'm a broad
heath ward councillor
and i chair the children's scrutiny
committee
um can i go to council on you
certainly yeah my name is adele mew and
i'm one of the councillors for buckler
award which is parsington carrington and
sail west
okay and councillor dylan
jane dylan i'm the labour councillor for
david hume east
okay and councillor blackburn
well good evening um i'm councilling the
blackburn councillor in village ward
thank you
okay and councillor bennett
good evening i'm joanne bennis i'm one
of the sale more counsellors
and jill can i ask you to introduce
yourself
good evening colleagues counsellors um
i'm jill mcgregor i'm the corporate
director for children's services here in
trafford
okay councillor london
i am councillor stephen london i'm one
of the councillors for brooklyn's
in sale east okay and councillor carter
hello i'm karina carter and i am the
lead member for education
as well as a counsellor for dave hume
west okay
and councillor young
good evening everyone i'm councillor for
hail central
hey i'm council hines hi
um i'm kath hines i'm the lead member
for children's services
i'm not actually a member of the
committee but i'm invited to attend the
meeting so thank you
very much for having me and i'm also a
um the counselor for earning student
ward
okay and i'm looking across the screen
so fabiola
searcher it's a fabiola foske and i'm
the governance officer
thank you thank you councillor jorge
i'm councillor sarah harhi and i
represent longford ward
councillor white hello i'm uh
counselor amy white i'm a world
counselor in broadhead
council of barclay
uh hello everybody i'm karen barkley i'm
one of the bowdoin wall councillors
and karen hello everybody karen samples
director of education for trafford
pamela hello pamela wharton director of
early help and children's social care in
trafford
and last but certainly not least john
hi everybody i'm john allison i'm the
council's governance manager and
statutory scrutiny officer
thank you and thanks everybody it's nice
to see some new faces
as well as some returnees to this
committee
um we've had apologies from councillors
acton and maitland and i believe
councillor
carey has given apologies he's unable to
attend this evening
unfortunately um
so the next item on the gender is
membership of the committee
and we have had the report and that's
the noting can that be noted
yeah and third item
is the terms of reference these are the
same
terms of reference as we had last year
so can those be noted
okay and are there any declarations of
interest from anybody
on the committee
no um
i'm not aware that we have any questions
from members of the public
okay
and item six is the minutes of the
previous meeting because everybody had
had a chance to read them and are there
any comments
or changes we need to make
no are we happy to accept those then
it's a true record
okay so the next item on the agenda
is the update on office said report
um the inspection of children's social
care services
we have had the report so if i could
just
ask that um i don't know who's
introducing this but could we just have
a
a quick overview rather than a line by
line please
um would it be helpful councillor
western if i start and invite pamela
to um add some detail in as we we go
along
and as you say we've produced a set of
slides that reflect
um not just the
the work that's been ongoing but some of
the more recent
um external scrutiny and validation
that we've had um what you will note
from the slides is that that
includes um a focus visit that was
conducted by ofsted
in march of this year
the final letter was produced in may of
this year
and i i think it would be helpful for us
to just spend a little bit of time
reflecting with the
with the committee um the significant
work that has gone on
throughout the pandemic but also um
some of the key highlights from the
ofsted findings
you will be aware that we have had an
improvement plan
and over the last year we have updated
that improvement plan to be
our eight ambitions plan
we felt it was really really important
that we described what we wanted to
aspire to
and what we needed to do for our
children and families in the borough
so we have worked with our partnership
to craft that that
ambitions plan the link for the
the plan is contained within the slide
deck
it was really important for us that we
didn't just respond to
ofsted but that we had a genuine focus
on what we thought would make the
biggest difference to
children and families in the borough
one of the things that obviously has
happened in the last year
is that we've needed to continue to work
on improvement activity whilst dealing
with a pandemic
and one of the things that i would
really like to pull out
for the committee is that one of the
first things that
ofsted said in in the le in the letter
that we got
following their visit was they
recognized that throughout the pandemic
senior leaders had worked effectively
with partners
to maintain provision and a continued
focus on practice improvement
they were also really clear that in
carrying out the focus
visit and it was a team of five
inspectors
and they said um that
the the focus would be narrow but the
scope would be wide
and they weren't um they were really
accurate in terms of saying that
because they went through every part of
the service
they also highlighted that they found a
developing culture of leaders and staff
being
open to learning welcoming feedback to
support
practice they were really clear that we
had presented a comprehensive
self-assessment that demonstrated we had
an accurate understanding of the quality
of practice
but christically that we were clear
about the work that we needed to do to
continue our improvements
and even more importantly that we had
accurate plans to address that
um they did highlight that there were
three
areas that we really needed to continue
to improve
one of which was the quality of planning
for children
one of which was the the management
oversight
including child protection chairs but
they felt that that was very much
um across the middle leadership layer
and
some of our support and planning for our
care leaders
i'd really like to highlight to the
committee this evening that we have had
our improvement board this morning
which is the formal arrangements for
monitoring our progress
and the work that we're doing and
at that board this morning
we were able to feed back that our
strength and management grip and quality
assurance is really starting to embed
so in may the last month where we had
our reporting um documented we had
87 compliance with our audit
requirements
70 of our audits included having a
reflective conversation with
practitioners
and for the committee i think it would
be really important to stress
the value of that reflective
conversation that means that senior
leaders and managers
are having conversations with the
practitioners about the quality of their
work
what they need to do to further
strengthen it what's going well
um the majority of our audits are now
identifying that practice
is um either requires improvement or
good
we're seeing a strengthening in the
quality of our assessments
with 21 of the most recent audits
highlighting
that the assessments were good um
we feel that we still have much more to
do
um but during the pandemic and over the
the since we last reported to committee
one of the things that we have done is
go back to basics
and some of the reason why i'm stressing
that is it's been particularly important
to us in the pandemic
to see our children and young people and
i can say that
for example with our care leavers we're
in touch with 84
of our care leaders who are age 17 to 18
slightly drops for our older care
leavers
because they sometimes say you know what
i'm alright and i don't want to see you
what i'm delighted with is the majority
of that keeping in touch's face-to-face
visits
so for example 95 of our children
subject to child protection plans
have had visits within the last four
weeks and again the majority of those
visits have been face-to-face
visits um they are some of the real
positives
the timeliness of our assessments has
improved
um some of the things that ofsted also
said to us
was about where children
or families are needing a safeguarding
response that they get that
that it's timely that it involves
multi-agency
information what they did feel though
was that um sometimes we were having
too many meetings at that point
of of need and some of that was about
how we harnessed
our our collective information
we've focused very much on practice
we've secured a strategic practice
improvement partner who's going to be
working intensively with us
and they've actually started that work
offstead further recognized that we'd
strengthened our
front door arrangements that when
children
are referred they get a timely response
but like i say
three areas that they did recognize we
needed to further strengthen
as you've already highlighted chair
there's a comprehensive slide deck that
highlights some of the ongoing work
that we're doing and at that point i'd
probably invite pamela
if she wants to add anything and open
open up for questions
okay thanks very much jill did you want
to come in on that pamela
thank you chair yeah just just really
just to add
in respect of the dfe review as well
which was
um a recent um review in in may that was
concluded
a number of strengths identified there
in terms of knowing ourselves well and
having clear plans in place
and i think one of the one of the
significant
improvements that we've seen in the last
six months certainly is
is around the ownership of the quality
assurance framework
across the service and managers at all
levels
looking at the quality of practice and
that was something that they commented
on
um i think what i would highlight which
links to the
our redesign as well um that we
currently
have started to implement is that we do
have some instability in the workforce
um the dfe highlighted that we've had
discussions in
in the improvement board this morning
around that
and we are really focusing on that
investing in our people
strategy so we've introduced a market
factor supplement
for experienced social workers in terms
of that that retention
and we have a recruitment and marketing
campaign
that colleagues within the hr team
are working with us on we are hoping
that that is going to be going live this
month
so that that recruitment as as trafford
as a place of
of choice for social workers um
that we we're really committed to
building a place
here where social workers and social
work practice
can flourish and so we've we've
commissioned
also a three-year practice improvement
program
with a provider called strengthening
practice
they are going to be working alongside
us through the summer as we implement
the redesign
and then there's going to be um an
in-depth program
building on work already completed with
our restorative
practice model um to
to really look at building those
relationships between workers and
families
and that's across early help and and
into children's social care
and and as a management team we will be
sitting alongside
and and being involved in that program
as well
so kind of bringing the workforce
together
i'll stop there and i will answer any
questions that people have
okay thanks pamela jill i you mentioned
that
um that this visit the scope was narrow
but the focus was wide
um looking at the letter it appears to
be
less broad in in scope i've just
wondered what the reasoning behind that
was um and the letter also hints at
considerable progress
but it doesn't actually focus on those
areas so it's
giving a much more negative tone
to the letter i just wondered just to
give
some context and assurance to committee
members
because the actual report sounds really
positive and forward thinking
i'm just um wondering if you could just
explain really that the parameters which
would make the the letter sound rather
more negative
um yes in terms of of the
the comments narrow in focus but broaden
scope
this was a focus visit that was carried
out under
um under the auspices of
really testing out how well local
authorities have responded
to managing the pandemic and
ofsted were really clear that the letter
wouldn't have
the usual um
charting of progress over over a period
of time that they would have a team that
was specifically
looking at how well we'd responded to
covid some of the management and the
decision making but it would be
every aspect of the service normally
as a local authority under um
an improvement um journey you would have
had a series of monitoring visits and it
would
would build on that and so as you will
have seen from the letter it goes
straight into the areas that are
recommendations for further improvement
but then the background of the letter
does highlight some progress
ofsted were really clear as well that
because it was
a visit that was carried out under
covert restrictions that the detailed
feedback that they gave us
um through the the 12-day process
would be more detailed than was
contained in the letter
so they did highlight that we had really
strengthened our management grip
like i say really pleasing to hear that
the senior team had a clear
understanding and focus on
on understanding ourselves but
critically that we have plans in place
that we're doing something about it
they really spent a considerable period
of time looking at our front door
arrangements which have been one of
their biggest concerns when they came in
in 2019 and so that comment about we've
strengthened the front door we've
continued to make progress in relation
to the front door
at that time was was really really
pleasing to see um the fact that we've
strengthened our partnership as pamela
has mentioned was one of the areas that
again dfe
um really pulled out in their their
six-month review
so it's right that ofsted are saying
there is more to do
we would absolutely agree with that
that's one of the reasons why we have an
ambitions plan rather than just an
improvement plan
one of the things that i thought was was
really pleasing for us to hear
was that comments that they've said
about senior leaders presented a
comprehensive self-assessment
that demonstrated we knew ourselves and
that we were starting to change the
culture to be
one of learning so mary is a practice
that they really
recognized were things like our complex
safeguarding our response to missing
so some areas that absolutely do need
strengthening but some
real areas of progress i've done
something with my
link so i can only see you denise in a
tiny little corner
okay i i'll before i open this up to
um questions from the committee members
there are a couple of um findings in the
most recent ofsted letter which have
concerned me slightly jill i just
wondered if i could raise these with you
and so on the list of findings it's the
second one
and it's the second sentence and which
reads decisions for some children
are not informed by a thorough
consideration of their history
or effective evaluation of the
information available
and this leads to them being the subject
of repeat requests for help
and experiencing delay before they
receive the right
service and the other
concern i have relates to and it's point
number 10 in the offstead letter
again the second um
sentence weak management oversight by
both
front line and more senior managers
means that where there is no progress
for children and their lives don't
improve
this is not identified or responded to
quickly enough
um these two remarks are particularly
worrying
and i wondered what assurance you can
give us that these issues
are being addressed properly and with
urgency so that these children are
helped as quickly
and responsibly as possible thanks jill
if
i'm just trying to find the relevant
points in terms of
the points that you've raised councillor
weston
but i think in terms of both of those
things
one of the things that i can say is um
we've done a lot of work
in terms of strengthening the front door
looking at whether we get help
right at the first time or not
and one of the things that i'm really
pleased to be able to report to the
committee
is our measure of whether we get help
right at the first time
is nationally is used through
re-referral rates
and at the time that ofsted came in and
visited us in 2019
our re-referral rate was 30 percent
as of this month our re-referral rate is
19
so that means in the majority of cases
we are making the right decisions that
we are getting
the right support to our families
and the timeliness of our assessments
has significantly improved
so understanding the needs of our
children and young people and our
families and the help that they want is
is really an improving picture
in relation to your second point about
what we're doing
to understand children's lived
experience their full histories and
whether we're getting that
right we have embarked on a programme of
work
introducing what's called child impact
chronology so not just recording
events for children and
the the significance of them but really
asking the question
what do we understand about the impact
of this event
on that child's life on that family's
life
and really um using that to inform the
quality of our assessments and our
planning
because if we don't understand what's
going on we can't understand
what is the right support and the right
intervention that we
we need to offer that programme of work
has gone live
um and an example of where it's showing
improving practice would be our recent
peer audit of our complex safeguarding
work
where peers came in did deep dives in
relation to
um cases where where
young people were being exploited or at
risk of exploitation
and in three quarters of the cases that
they looked at and it was only a sample
of four but they looked at police
information
our information and health information
three out of
those four cases had a child impact
chronology
and they were really clear that um
that was helping inform how we were
managing
risk our partners have asked that we
work with them to roll out that
methodology in terms of child impact
chronologies so they're a couple of ways
in which we're really tackling and
addressing those issues
and we have also introduced
our conversational audit process which
means having conversations with children
and families
about their experience of our services
and saying did we get it right what
would have made a difference to you can
we further strengthen that
and we're really using that to to close
the loop in terms of some of our service
delivery
i can see that um other colleagues want
to come in and i know pamela will want
to say
there's much more besides jill that
we're doing so
if it's all right can i invite pamela to
to further add to the response counselor
western
yes of course thanks for thanks for that
that is reassuring thank you jill um
thank you chair and what i will say is
is that we
we have reviewed um some of our decision
making points as well along the child's
journey
and we are strengthening those
arrangements
with moving to a panel function
and and having legal colleagues with us
in a panel where
where we make those decisions and
reviewing all of the associated
documentation there so that we're asking
the right questions
of our practitioners and asking the
managers to
to add their analysis and their
oversight
and so that we we envisage that will
strengthen the decision-making
particularly when we're looking to
do we need to we've have we have a child
protection plan in place
that's not effective um at the moment
of the 190 children that we have on a
child protection plan
and five of those have been on a champ
protection plan for
for more than two years so we will be
we're reviewing
those five children just to make sure
that um
that that's the right place for their
their needs to be overseen and the risks
to be managed
and we do also do that at 18 months as
well to prevent
um that delay but that that's a small
proportion which i'm quite pleased with
um but we will just make sure that those
children have
have the right plan for them we're also
introducing as
is referenced in the presentation
multi-agency audits
um and so we we have also a number of
partner liaison meetings with our police
colleagues and our school colleagues and
health colleagues
where they are raising cases with us and
in in that forum we are also raising
things with them that we've seen
um so we're having a lot of dialogue
about
children and about where where plans are
for children and what we need to do
together to move those forward
we will also be doing a multi-agency
audit at the front door
um this month as well
thanks pamela i believe councillor
bennett did you have a question or a
point to me
thank you chair it's very clear that a
large part of the workforce are agency
staff
and i'm just curious if that's having a
detrimental
impact on how the improvement plan is
going
it's not clear how long an agency staff
remain
remains in post so i'd be interested to
know
uh how you coping with that thank you
if i can answer in the first instance
and then bring pamela in
our aspiration is to have as many
permanent staff
as as we need um pamela has already
referenced our service redesign
and that that actually
includes a significant investment from
the council with an increase of 21
additional social workers across the
service
pamela referenced the fact that we have
introduced a market factor supplement
for experienced social workers and that
was following a really detailed piece of
analysis that was carried out
with um colleagues from um hr
and the service to really look at the
points at which
um we were attracting social workers
what their level of experience were
where we had some instability in the
workforce and
and how we kept pace in terms of
matching with
other local authorities
what we recognize though is that
financial remuneration is only one part
of stabilizing the workforce that
actually how you look after people the
quality of supervision the quality of
their induction their experience of
being
nurtured and looked after
as an employer is really critical to
what we're doing
so the the level of agency staffing that
we have at the moment
is higher than we would like we're
working very hard
in our investors in people strategy that
covers
all aspects like i say how we introduce
new people
how we grow our own staff how we support
people one of the key pieces of work
that we've got
ongoing is our work on our supervision
framework
that's actually being led by
practitioners
and some of our practice leaders
to develop the type of support the type
of supervision that they would find
most helpful interestingly
we have had some of our agency staff
convert
um to becoming permanent staff for us
inevitably if somebody isn't with us on
a permanent basis and
can leave us at short notice that does
have an impact on quality of practice
which is one of the reasons why we will
always have a need for example when
we have people are sick or maternity
leave which can be up to a year now
um but our ambition has to be to have as
many permanent staff
that want to stay in trafford because
the
they're well looked after we are an
employer of choice
and they have opportunities to learn and
develop and grow
so you're absolutely right councillor
bennett too many agency staff
but that's why one of our key priorities
has to be investing in our people
and reducing that number down
thanks jill do any of the members of the
committee have any questions
oh right okay so councillor blackburn
and then
councillor longdon thank you
um i just wanted to to ask a couple of
things um with regard to
um instability in in the workforce
our social work is moving within gm
or to other areas of the country and
if they're moving within gm
how how do the sort of
heads of service in each borough um but
you know
you know when you're having your sort of
you know your your meetings
how if that's the case how how are they
responding to
to you know to the wave movement if it
is within gm
um and also could i ask do we have a
leaving interview with
staff in order to to to sort out
why people are leaving and um
[Music]
and and sort of my last point is and the
sort of sicknesses stroke absences
during
during covid um has have
have they had any um effects on
um sort of individuals wanting to leave
trafford so councillor blackburn if i
can start with your middle question
first in terms of um
do we carry out exit interviews yes we
do carry out exit interviews
and we offer our practitioners
and any member of staff that chooses to
leave trafford
the opportunity to have that exit
interview
independent of their line management
arrangements so as they can speak
candidly about the the reasons why they
might
um feel that trafford isn't the right
place for them
for some people it is very much because
they've had
promotional opportunities that they are
choosing to do
different things um so we have had
some people leave and go to cafcass the
court service
where um where practitioners represent
children within care proceedings
we have had some people leave and go to
different parts of the countries we've
had somebody leave and go to portugal
for example
prior to being able to go
to another
i think you're frozen jill
shall i shall i come in in jill's
absence until she gets her
her connection back so just
just to just to build on what what jill
was saying really many
many varied reasons for for people
moving on
i do think that that corvid pandemic not
just in the social work profession
but across a number of professions has
caused people
to rethink their priorities in life and
some people have made
decisions to leave and social work and
and try
other and career opportunities
and what we do know from from our exit
interviews because we do undertake
a thematic analysis of those
is is that um support um
is really important for people um and
although
there might be personal circumstances
and reasons for leaving
what some of the people are telling us
when they're leaving is
is they've not felt as well supported as
as they feel they need to be to do this
this job
and so that's why we are we are
re-looking at our investing in people
strategy we are talking with our
managers about in this virtual world
how you support your staff and how you
enable that resilience
um we we do have that roadmap um
to bring more people into the building
now
there was um a national research paper
um done a couple of months ago which was
about um
newly qualified social workers it will
be the same in teaching i guess or
health visiting
that this last year 18 months has been
an incredibly difficult
year for people starting in their
profession
and the anchors the anchors that i had
back in 1995 when i started
i'm not sure that i would have made it
as a social work practitioner
in in this current environment so the
sooner we can get our people
in safely um to start that work as teams
and and that that physical space and
being together
and i think that will will see
significant improvements
and what i will say is we have six
frontline practitioners so we've trained
this last year
six social workers as part of the
frontline methodology which is a
national
dfe model who who want to stay with us
we have three student social workers
who've completed their final year
placement with us
who want to stay with us and we've
shortlisted
for a further six social workers this
week
um so we are we are really
uh prioritizing it's one of our key
priorities
is that stability of the workforce and
making sure that once people
arrive with us that they're looked after
really well
we have just to go back to the point on
on agency workers
with several agency workers who have
chosen to remain with us as permanent
workers
um i did another session last week for
agency workers who were thinking
um about joining us there were 10 people
on that call
so that that's really positive i have
two agency managers at the moment who
are saying
we really like it here when when the
rules become available we like to apply
so in the midst of the instability and
and it's significant for children and
families
who might be on their third social
worker this year
that is huge for them and that's not
what we want for children and families
but we are working very hard to get to a
position
where we have stability so that the the
worker that grabs that family sees them
through
to whatever whatever permanence and
approach is right for that child
thanks very much pamela um
council london did you have a question
yeah i did share but to be fair i think
um counselor dylan had a hand up before
me so i'm happy to refer to her first
that's fine sorry um counselor dylan i
didn't see your hand so
it's fine i didn't know who's what's up
when this is fine um
just could i ask about feedback from
children and young people
um on page
it mentions care levers i think it's at
page 19 of the
presentation i can't find it now
it's mentions care leavers um we're
sorry sorry sorry where are we
right i found it no i haven't
it just mentioned care leavers didn't
feel it was
as happy with things as obviously you
are
i just wondered about how do you get
feedback from the children and young
people
throughout the changes that you've been
making over the last few years
and also do you have any idea when ofted
will be satisfied with the progress that
you
you're clearly making and that's all
really from me thank you
i'm not sure whether jill's back but
i'll i'll i'll start if that's okay and
i'm sure if she gets back she
she will dip in and i think you're
absolutely right
counselor dylan we did we did reference
in there it was in the ofsted letter
and in their feedback to us that some of
our care leavers
who had been spoken to as part of the
the visit and
were um were not positive
about some of the the access to
emotional health and well-being services
during um corvid and two of them in
particular
had had um real difficulties in terms of
of their emotional mental health and we
have obviously followed up
those young people following that
conversation
and we are improving in terms of our
performance
on keeping in touch with with our young
people because if you don't have the
conversations with
with young people you don't know what
the issues are so we're really
um making improvements there in the
numbers of young people that we we're
speaking to on on a regular basis
as jill referred to it's really timely
that you should ask around
um the engagement of children young
people we had a presentation
um this morning at the improvement board
which was around
um that voice and that that
participation
and the work work that we're doing there
much more to do
on that on that journey and but there
was some really insightful
um feedback from young people involved
with you justice
and that was shared um as well and we do
have um a for a forum for cared for
children
um and we do have a forum for um
care experience young people i i've go
along to those forums
we took the redesign um a couple of
months ago to seek their their views
um on that but absolutely brilliant
question because it is it is an
area that we are very focused on in
terms of needing to improve
that experience and that voice in in the
presentation
and we do refer to um child's journey
meetings and councillor hines had the
privilege of being able to
attend one of those recently where as as
a partnership we come together to look
at
the journey of the child through their
eyes and
which will then lead us to understand
their experiences and formulate
a plan that's going to work for them so
that's that's a methodology
around the no wrong door model that we
have that we
are um cascading out
to come on to the second part of you
your question if i'm here
in terms of when will offset be
satisfied
um we we have agreed um that we will
have a further monitoring visit
in the autumn so we will in september or
october have a further visit
it will be two inspectors i think this
time and it will be
on on one particular area of the
framework which is help and protection
so looking at our child protection
planning
um following that we will have our
annual conversation with ofsted in
january
this every local authority children's
services have an annual conversation
and from that we will together determine
and what's the best point for them to
come back and fully inspect us
which we expect to be next spring
thank you pamela and thank you
councillor dylan for the question
counselor london can i come to you for
your question please
thanks chair um thank you to jill uh
pamela for for all the work they're
doing and
setting out um the reports they've given
us this evening
and to be doing that in such difficult
circumstances over the last 18 months um
it's really remarkable it's good to see
that australia recognizing the
improvements even even
regardless of those difficult
circumstances you're working in
so well done um
i think for me that the
the thing that stood out most in in the
report that joe's provided was on slide
16
where jill highlighted the fact that
ofsted said that our practice
is still too variable and
i think you know that it does begin to
to kind of get little bells ringing in
my head because obviously whenever
you've got variability
and you've always got risk associated
with that
and i think from what i've heard this
evening
we talked about the availability
of staff and the obstacles you're facing
there
and the impact that that help will have
on um
consistent service provision and we've
just heard
about some of the work you're doing with
care leavers
to ascertain where they see the
variability
and you you're focusing on that which is
really good to hear
um and i can see as well from jill's
report that you
have put quite an emphasis
on undertaking audits of the service as
part of your
um regular day in day out practice
from reading jill's report and from from
what gilbert was saying i get the
impression that
that auditing is not particularly
well embedded as yet and do correct me
if i'm wrong on that
and i'm wondering if that is perhaps one
of the keys where he can once that does
get embedded
we'll get a much better and deeper
understanding of the reasons for the
variability and therefore the risk
jill did actually say in her
introduction remarks that
21 of the recent audits are good
that raised the question in my mind does
that mean 79
of the audits are telling us things are
not good or require improvement
if that's the case that seems quite a
significant number
so yeah i just really want to get an
understanding of what you're doing as a
service to really
dig down and find out the causes of that
variability
in service provision
i'll i'll come if in if i'm a um
counselor london and thank thank you
very much
it has been it has been um
a very different improvement journey to
what i'm used to this is my fourth
improvement journey in children's social
care and my first in a pandemic
so the the challenges that that brings
um have have been significant um
and you you you might not um kind of
scan the horizon but there are a number
of other local authorities
in improvement during this time who have
not made the progress that we have made
we've continued to innovate and we've
continued to push forward with some pace
as well as delivering services um and
increasing demand
uh and redesigning um services
so and thank you very much that's it's
it's really i've
reflect i'll reflect that back to to the
workforce
i think when when offset came in in
march
we we were having still some
conversations with managers about
um your audits are due but we've not yet
got them
um but i'm pleased to say that um
for april may and june we have had
a significant improvement in the number
of audits that managers
are completing and also alongside that
an in
increase in the number of moderations so
where we look and test out
the judgments that managers have come to
um at a more senior level
and what we're seeing from that work
is that there is more now alignment
between
what the managers are seeing and saying
about the practice that they are
overseeing and conversations with
practitioners
with what ourselves the senior managers
are saying are seeing
for quite a while there was a real
disconnect
and and and there was um where where
managers would say i think this is good
and myself or or another senior leader
would come along and say
that that's not quite hitting good and
these are my reasons why
but we've we have now got more alignment
um and the ver the variability
in practice um is is an area where we
we are mindful of we have a whole
programme
of um learning and development so we
have lunch and learn sessions
so where through the quality assurance
we are seeing
a particular issue we will put a bespoke
package in place we had a sessions on
ginagrams which is the map of the family
which really helps you as a practitioner
understand
and who's in this child's life and we
weren't we weren't seeing that they were
being used
we delivered some lunch and learn
sessions on one of those sessions there
were 64 practitioners came
and we are we are able to demonstrate
through the quality assurance that we
are seeing an improvement
in in in genograms similarly what jill
was saying about child impact
chronologies
we are starting to see and an increase
on those and then being in place for
children and
informing decision makings much more to
do
um in that respect but that first-line
management of
of social workers and and social care
practitioners
is absolutely crucial and as part of our
redesign
and we are condensing the three layers
of management that we have into two
we're going to have a really clear roles
and responsibilities and delegated
decisions
and that the new practice managers the
operational managers
will have wholesale responsibility for
the quality of practice in their team
there is a program being built for them
in terms of
their their skills knowledge moving into
those roles
and so i'm i'm hopeful that with putting
these
these things into place we will start to
reduce the variability of that practice
you very much pamela um and thank you to
jill
um and to all the offices involved
in producing the reports and for your
very
knowledgeable and comprehensive answers
to our questions
um if i may you're more than welcome to
stay pamela
let's move on to the next item which is
the school readiness update
um i believe we have karen and zoe here
um again we have had site of the
report in advance so if you could give
us a quick overview
and then i'd like to open up the floor
for um questions by committee members
thank you thank you councillor weston
i'm
actually going to pass straight over to
to zoe sweeney
um who will introduce herself and her
position uh within the early years
service and she'll go through the main
highlights in the report thank
thanks you much for that karen um yeah
my name's zoe sweeney and i'm the
early year service manager here in
trafford
um and have some oversight of
early years and um not artifact
strategic board with cameron
so if i just um give a quick summary um
of the report
and you you will know um i'm sure
that trafford has a very uh strong
early years sector of which we are
really proud
and we've got a very high quality
provision in trafford um with
98 of child minders graded good and
outstanding
uh which is above national um and also
98
of what we would call our group settings
that's our nurseries and our preschools
that are graded good and outstanding
which again is higher than national
and i think it's really important you
know school readiness
means different things to different
people doesn't it
and in some ways we've tried to reflect
that in the report because it's not just
about
attainment about whether children reach
you know that good level of development
at age five that's really important but
we know
it's obviously about the holistic
support that they get
and i think that that's reflected in our
early years
not to find strategic board planning
and and as you will see in the report we
have a
a series of ambitions um of which
one is early education and the outcomes
but the other ones are around
the a thousand and one critical days
that's the naught to two
um special educational needs and how
we're meeting uh the needs of those
children and families
the integrated work speech language and
communication which i can talk about
all day and it's a huge passion of mine
and i think you know we've done a lot of
work in trafford
narrowing what's called the word gap and
and the other huge pieces of work for us
are around um social and emotional
well-being of which we know
is a huge issue um for our families
and our children and that wellbeing so
what i'd like to just say is that um
we have that plan already in place
pre-em
pre-covered however we quickly
recognized
that we needed to re-look at that plan
the ambitions still very much remained
the same
but the priorities that sat below them
and our action planning
needed to be concise uh it needed to be
focused
and we needed to think about what we
were doing at pace and i can give plenty
of examples around speech language and
communication about what we've been
doing during the pandemic
and also around our special educational
needs and some of
the workforce training that we've
continued
during lockdowns to our earlier sector
um you know it's been absolutely immense
um and i know our health visitors have
been doing lots of work trying to
reach the families to reach those
mandated visits to support early
identification
in terms of our school readiness data um
it's probably worth me explaining that
like many other um performance data
um the dfe um have um have said that
this is not a statutory requirement at
the moment
so um they didn't want to burden um
early year settings in schools which is
absolutely understandable
what that does mean for us is that we
don't have any comparable data at the
end of this year
to be able to um quantify if you like
some of the
impact of the um of the pandemic
however um i can talk more about what
we're doing locally
to assess that because then we are
working collaboratively to try and uh
get some of that data um to give us a
further picture
i think what's really important when
we're talking about our
data and school readiness is to
absolutely highlight
the performance journey that we'd
already been on
so actually we had made significant
strides
um on what we call narrowing the gap
and with our more vulnerable our
disadvantaged um
children you'll be well aware that
overall
traffic performs really well and
for our early years children with 75
of children achieving what's called a
good level of development at the age of
five
and what we do know is obviously this
masks
some of the challenges that we know we
have in some of our
what we call our school readiness areas
and some other pockets across the
borough
and and we've done significant work in
2019
to improve and narrow that gap and i can
talk more about that in terms of
the data if required
sorry i'm just checking um so i think i
think for us
in terms of uh 2019
we know that there's still something to
do around
partington and the north locality
and i know as well that
um we have some particular cohorts of
children
um where we um would like to improve
some of the outcomes and that's
particularly
some of our boys um in partington
and an area in the north as well
so i think um what i think is also
really important to say
is in terms of the impact of hovid
and we can report that we don't have any
sufficiency issues in trafford that
we're aware of
so that that means
that means that everybody um who needs a
place
um has has got a place we have very high
three and four year old tape up
of places which places are seventh
nationally um in the country
and um we also know that our two-year
at the take-up of our two-year places um
is is significantly higher than the
national average
this has dropped slightly to 88
in the spring term but this is still
significantly higher
than national average um that doesn't
mean we won't be looking into that
and watching that carefully um
parental confidence has increased we've
got over 6 000
children attending regularly that
attendance has been maintained in our
uh dfe return and
we have identified some real key themes
of which i've already talked about which
is speech language and communication
you will see in the report that in the
absence of data
we have undertaken some analysis
um with some earlier settings and
schools in partington
who um very helpfully shared
um some speech and language data with us
in october of 2020 so that's at the
start
of the academic year and that
demonstrated
the real impact um of the pandemic
on the word gap where we had
um in our uh early years pbi
uh nurseries um
with a cohort of 44 children not all the
children it's got to be
noted 91 were not age-related
expectation
um likewise in school reception
50 um were
not age-related expectations but that
was with a small cohort of 20 children
and sorry that's in school nurseries and
in school reception
61 were not an age-related expectation
what i do need to point out is that we
have a lot of strategies that we know
work so um for some of those children
the welcome
intervention um can
is is absolutely showing a good impact
and for those children who get some
support
with that there was a 52 reduction
in some of the speech and language
difficulties that they were facing
we also know that social emotional
well-being is an issue and that's
obviously because of
the challenges that families have been
facing during this uh pandemic
um young children have faced you know
issues like bereavement
increased stress and pressure in the
family um
and you know that's something that our
early years sector have been supporting
children
and families with on a day-to-day basis
as well as some of our other colleagues
here today obviously from children's
services
in terms of physical development has
also been
an issue we know that
children may not have been able to play
out
and have the physical exercise and
movement um
that they may have got within their
early education
settings um and
we also know uh that for example there
are certain groups of children
where we absolutely want to focus on so
for example
we know that our reception children have
had
a disrupted early education experience
and through no thought of their own have
missed out on a significant
period of their early years education
so um that's been a particular focus for
us
in thinking about what these children
might need
when they move to year one because what
we need to be looking at
is how we ensure that they get the right
experiences that they've missed out on
just because they're not in their early
education setting
it doesn't mean that they can't um
schools can't support them
in terms of those early experiences and
that education that they might have
missed
in their early education setting so
we're doing a lot of work with
schools and head teachers in trafford
and across gm
and looking at that and i'll move on
very quickly to some of the strategists
i want to leave time for questions
um we have a wide scale speech
language and communication approach
across our early years sector
which includes um the welcome screening
tool and i can explain more about what
that is
and if people require a third of our
schools i've also
signed up to the nuffield early language
intervention programme which has been
developed by the dse
and i would like to add that we had
already started
a pilot in trafford ahead of the dfe
rollout
where we were already piloting this with
some of our schools
and i'm very pleased to say that um
this has now been rolled out and will be
extended to all schools
um for reception classes and we will be
encouraging our schools to sign up from
that
uh it's also called nelly and we will be
supporting what we're going to call
trafford nelly networks and that will be
where we support schools through these
uh
through this programme um
one of the things that i do want to
raise and i know that we have
um counsellor new here tonight who is a
child minder and
i'd like to um really reassure that
one of the pieces we're moving forward
is actually we're going to be extending
the reach of our speech and language
work
to our child minders of which we have to
um 211 in trafford
and so we're going to have a big
programme of work
and supporting speech language and
communication
for child minders to make sure that
there's equity
across the sector but equity for those
children
wherever they are in their early
education settings whatever kind of
provision
they um they attend um
we're doing a lot of work around feel
good early years which is our
social and emotional offer in our early
education
settings which is run by our early years
educational psychologist we're very
excited about that
we have a comprehensive workforce offer
across the sector and i am really
pleased to report that
during lockdown we still had 34
special educational needs coordinated in
early years
complete level 3 qualification that's
over a third nearly a third of
um early years group settings and we'll
be rolling something similar out to
child minders across trafford
um the other thing that i would like to
point out before i i move on in case
there's any questions
is that throughout the whole of the
pandemic and still
currently we track
all of our children um who are in
receipts of social
care with a social worker we track
attendance every week to ensure that
they
are attending their early years setting
and if there is an
absence we um contact the social worker
we verify that absence and that's to
make sure that our most vulnerable
children
um are absolutely receiving
the early education um offer that they
uh deserve um so i think
on that um i will pause
just to see i don't know whether karen
there's anything else that you want to
add that
i've missed there and if there's any
other questions no i think it'll
probably be
a good opportunity councillor weston if
we open it up for questions now
yeah absolutely do does anybody have any
questions
and thank you so much for what was um a
really positive and reassuring
and very comprehensive report and very
impressed
um does anybody have any questions at
all
i think you might be getting off here
oh i'm not young did you have a question
it's just um just quite a small one
you were talking about at one point
reference was made to the fact that the
birth rate in trafford is is um
going down a little bit
i wondered are we do we keep records or
we must do
about the families that come into
trafford
as families i'm thinking of where there
are
i know i know we're taking account of
areas where there are going to be
new buildings of houses that will
that will be new families coming in but
there is a big
sort of big sort of um
organizations that have been moving into
the area
with the i'm thinking of things like the
bbc
that are coming in and they'll have
their children there's this enormous
park being built near the airport which
is taking
quite a huge number of um
families are coming in and i'm just
wondering if there's any rise
in children with these families that
might make
any balance out with the falling birth
rates
sorry zoe she'll actually kind of start
and then maybe zoe i'm sure you'll talk
about sort of the
sufficiency in the early years sector
because we are a netting portion i'm
sure so we will want to
to report on that councillor young but
um in terms of
um sort of impact on school places
and places for certainly those children
going into nursery or into reception
and this you're absolutely right we have
a whole range of data sets that we apply
um including gp data um as well as our
you know admissions team that that holds
a a depth of data to to support school
place planning so
we we do factor those in and i think you
know we
we have seen that um the majority of our
reception for september um we have been
able to provide a school place for them
and there are very few surplus places
what we
what we are seeing is certain parts of
the borough where we are seeing some uh
surplus places and so i think at the
moment yes some of some of the housing
developments some of the
corporations and the businesses that are
bringing in the families
um they are absolutely plugging the gaps
for for
you know the potential for for a drop in
birth rate
what we also did across gm because we
noticed that there'd been an impact on
the number of reception applications
this year
we did um a bit of a reach out a social
media reach out or a comms reach out
just to make sure that during covered
parents haven't forgotten
to apply for a school place in reception
as well again just to make sure that
that we weren't missing any of the
information there
um but in trafford you know we we there
are very few
uh spare places if you like uh
particularly in reception in the early
years but zoey will probably want to
talk about
us in terms of the um nursery and pvi
sector
yeah that's right thank you and i think
the other thing just to say is there's a
national decline in birth rate as well
so that's um
that is being seen across across the
board
um yes i think um we are exceptionally
lucky
in trafford in the fact that we do have
an absolute buoyant early education and
child care
offer and and we absolutely know that we
do
have um enough places in all of our
localities and that's certainly not been
the case in other
local local authority areas where where
i've worked so um i think we um
the other thing that's really
interesting is we i think the
we don't we don't get data in some ways
about families moving
into the area until they apply for a
school place so it's really
difficult for us to quantify the
families that are coming in or trying to
access the early
education places because we also know
some families
before they reach their early education
entitlement age if you like
obviously um are often a lot of private
fee payers if you like in early
education settings that we wouldn't
necessarily
know about so what often happens with
sufficiency is
um we we know we haven't got an issue
because we don't have any um
information coming through that suggests
that we do and we know that we've got
surplus places
available in the in the early years
sector
thank you for that i believe councillor
dylan has
a question thank you
um just on page three of five
section b speech language and
communication
um it's not a question really it's just
an observation
the first sentence where it says
increase screen time blah blah blah
i just want to say that i found that
word wording really
uncomfortable and um i just wanted to
get that across i just i think it sounds
a little bit judgy and
because anybody can access this document
i just
i'm not happy with that word and just
wanted to say that thank you
thanks thanks for that feedback and
we'll we'll we'll absolutely
um really reflect on that
um i think um i think one of the things
that we
um have all grappled with in this
pandemic
and me included is that we're spending a
lot of time
aren't we on on technology and um
i think um i i think i want to kind of
make the point
absolutely take that on board that um
uh i i will absolutely um amend that
kind of information
it it's definitely not coming from a
place of
um of judgment but um
a place where i think we've all been
struggling with um increased technology
over
over the pandemic and that's certainly
something that our teachers have
reported but
um i absolutely take that comment on
board and
apologize if it's come across in that
way
yeah thank you cancer dylan just uh
completely
understand you know the the sometimes
the clumsiness i suppose of some of the
language used
and i think what we are trying to
highlight is we recognize that
um you know that we are seeing when when
children are um as as kind of zoe's
trying to explain through the welcome
screen and we are seeing that rising
in kind of the word gap of the
vocabulary gap and it could be for a
whole host of reasons so
um but we absolutely note uh your your
comment there it's really helpful thank
you
thank you both i'm just trying to check
in chats
i think i've got councillor blackburn
and councillor london if i'm correct i'm
not sure if they're
new questions or if they're legacy hands
um
councillor blackburn did you have a
question
uh yes thank you could i just ask i know
after the first lockdown
um there were some parents that were
um worried about sending the little ones
back to school um has there been
any indication that this has continued
to be so um you know about having their
you know their little ones you know
mixing with others
um you know as a school governor it's be
you know it was discussed um you know at
my school but
some and i know for a fact that
a lot of parents have got um an added
respect for you know the teachers
and the teaching assistants that they
didn't have before
um and rightly so but it's just
me mainly you know the first part i
wondered about
thank you councillor blackman and that's
a really kind comment actually that i'm
sure you know many people would would
really welcome
um it's interesting actually we did a
big piece of work on covid anxious
um and this was particularly across the
the school um sector not necessarily the
pvi
sector um because obviously it's when
children are a statutory school age
really
and clearly as the government kind of
shifted its thinking that actually
attendance was mandatory
we did a lot of work in children who
were not attending or families that were
really reluctant to send their children
in
simply because they were so so anxious
um about the impact of covid
and certainly our behavior and
attendance
support team worked
with some of those families as well to
support them and we actually set up
emergency
um almost like early help panels again
for schools to bring those cases to
discuss so that we could get a
multi-agency response
again to provide the right level of
support for those families
to try and increase the confidence uh to
support schools in getting the right
messages out into the
into the communities as well and
actually we saw a real shift then
in in in providing those assurances i
think that families needed
but i mean overall our attendance did
was quite high actually
and throughout covid and has certainly
remained high other than obviously when
when bubbles are popping and so on and
so forth
and and we've always done a deliberate
scrutiny on children with an ehc
and also children who may be known to
social care
um but you're absolutely right that that
was around but but we did try and tackle
it through a multi-agency approach
but zoe i don't know whether you've got
anything to add from the rest of the
early years sector
no i think i think you've covered it
there really we found that confidence
picked up quite
quite quickly and i think the other
difference i think was
when um when we went into the
the last lockdown if you like and the
last significant one
um early years settings remained open
to all and i think in some ways that
um i think i think the reassurance of
knowing that that they were open
and and and after all the parents
experiences of kind of struggling
through the first lockdown working
looking after children
and i think we did find that that that
confidence was quite high
thank you i can't see that any other
members
um have questions so thank you both very
much for the report
and for your very comprehensive answers
and
and you're more than welcome to stay but
um if you wish to leave i'm conscious
that
my room's gone dark i'm struggling to
read my papers then
now but uh thank you again and i'm going
to move on to
item nine of the agenda which is the
draft work programme for
2021-22 um
we have um a couple of items we have a
ofsted as a regular update hopefully
um i think our meetings the 8th of
october
so hopefully it would be post the um
autumn offstead visit so we will have we
will request an update anyway um
i had requested um the report on
the send peer review which unfortunately
wasn't ready in time for this meeting
but hopefully we can be able to bring
that to committee in october
um we've also submitted
um two pieces of task and finished work
to the executive
so i would expect um but one was on
um excp so i think we'd quite like an
update
on that for those of us that worked on
the task of finish group
and the most recent one which went to
exec a couple of weeks ago
um was on scnd exclusions
and so i'm just wondering if there are
any other
um topics that
members would be interested in looking
at
and i know councillor new had emailed me
prior to the meeting
and asking about the impact of covid on
the
early years foundation stage is that
something i know it was particularly
imparting since council and you
is that something you'd like an update
on perhaps for the next meeting
yeah okay so if that would be okay
karen and zoe yeah that that's
absolutely fine can i just check
counseling you um in terms of the early
years foundation stage are we
talking about um kind of good level of
development
um are we talking about just early early
years across the board
perhaps we can take that offline and we
can certainly agree a line of focus but
just to make sure it's helpful to to you
absolutely
really as sort of as broad as we can
make it but you know that's fine
yeah no problem thank you
no problem that's great thank you and
something i
thought of would um i would certainly
like to look after is to see how
um covid has um impacted on our looked
after children
specifically um i attend the corporate
parenting board and
we do have updates um from um the looked
after children
and at some of the meetings well at most
of the meetings and
the the children in care are actually
present um
so it's really interesting i don't know
if we'd be able to facilitate that
for um the october meeting if that's
something committee members
would be interested in if there's
anything else that people can think of
um i don't know if there's any views
yet uh counselor dr barclay
thank you so much chairman um yes
because i'm just suggesting and see if
the rest of the um
uh committee are interested in this
topic and obviously we know that kobe's
had a massive impact on children's
education
and we are trying really hard i know
within trafford to kind of have a
catch-up programme
for the children who've been impacted
and clearly we know also that obviously
the children who
need the most support from education and
and need to get the most out of
education
probably suffered the worst in fact and
i just wondered if we could perhaps
scrutinize
the implementation and effectiveness of
the catch-up programmes within trafford
so uh i don't know chad you want me i
mean certainly
uh councillor barkley um certainly
schools are monitored
in terms of the impact of of catch up um
we
are putting into place quality assurance
visits for all of our schools in the
autumn term
we've actually appointed associate
school improvement advisors to support
the team so we can get into every school
and part of the qa monitoring will be
around the
obviously the impact of catch-up whether
that's the catch-up funding
tutoring whatever it is that the schools
have actually um put into place so
more than happy to draft some level of
report around that absolutely
that's that's great thank you karen um
i will leave it open we're always
flexible with the work program
um if you have any ideas or as things
arise through the year
if you please contact either myself
or and or fabiola and um we can look at
fitting those onto
um the agendas for future meetings um
i just wanted to mention just prior to
covid
and we've set up a task and finished
group to look at tams which is now
healthy young minds um unfortunately
we've not been able to continue with
that um
through throughout the covid period
hopefully once things start to open up
again
it's something that is of great concern
to me
and we met with these students virtually
from trafford college
and that was um there was major concerns
there
of the impact um on our children and
young people
of the pandemic and so i think it's
something
that we really need to look at and if
anybody else is
interested in um joining us in the task
and finish group
you'd be most welcome and hopefully we
can get that up and running again
um during the summer um
so if i'm okay to move on i'm not aware
of any urgent business
which is the final item on the agenda
so with that um i'd like to thank
everybody for coming
both members and officers and um
also members of the executive um who
have had a
quite a peaceful evening i must say
councillors then
carter and heinz for a change try again
yeah
um but i would just like to bid
everybody good night
and um have a safe journey to where
wherever you're uh
moving to from your computer screen so